seal hour buys official
information regretting the siege closer to
draw and later ambulance
dry enough food here is
provided assistance on the spot
directly and our colleagues
do not have the heart of the baron completely turns out the
situation here is under control from the
point of view I want to say once again
when the shares of appetite are meter zone  games
about the cordon in this case, that
is, out of boredom, the ladies could clearly
fly there and at a fairly large
distance now the situation is localized
in this case from selenium and there will only be
houses in the immediate vicinity of
the nearby military airfield,
now I enter directly on the
spot.  and in this case, what is the
amount of damage there, but the main commissions here and
this
[music]
for housing is very good you
were sitting under the garages then you generally thought
there and to stay
these explosions were we hid under
fortune telling we didn’t know where to go because
the apartment was immediately abandoned  the waters ran away,
they took all the
smoke, the scream, the scream of the inhabitants of this house,
probably someone was injured by fragments
, and
we decided,
and then it was a rout on our feet and began to
explode
[music]